formerly what has been said can be expressed
thus the general state of the judgment or
proposition which involves the distinction
of subject and predicate is destroyed by the
speculative proposition and the proposition
of identity which the former becomes contains
the counter thrust against that subject predicate
relationship this conflict between the general
form of a proposition and the unity of the
notion which destroys it is similar to the
conflict that occurs in rhythm between meter
and accent rhythm results from the floating
center and the unification of the two so too
in the philosophical proposition the identification
of subject and predicate is not meant to destroy
the difference between them which is the form
of the pro which the form of the proposition
expresses their unity rather is meant to emerge
as a harmony the form of the proposition is
the appearance of the determinate sense or
the accent that distinguishes its fulfillment
but that the predicate expresses the substance
and that the subject itself it falls into
the universal this is the unity in which the
accent dies away
in section 61 hegel is continuing this discussion
about subjects and predicates and about the
forms of propositions or judgments and why
does he say proposition or judgment because
these are two different acts or two different
products of the the reasoning the thinking
individual or just the repeating individual
as well the mimic and what's going on in these
when one makes a judgment one predicates something
of a subject that's the grammatical form of
it and we're often tempted to think that the
logical form in the sense of what's really
going on in the intelligibility of what what's
being talked about is the same thing as the
grammatical form as a matter of fact for some
people you know they're willing to collapse
logic and grammar into each other hegel wants
to resist that not because you know he thinks
that grammar is something special or even
logic is is something you know intrinsically
special but because that just doesn't fit
the way that consciousness actually develops
in the way that consciousness grasps things
that's what this section whether you realize
it or not is really about he's saying formally
expressed you know here's what we can say
about this and we'll come to that in just
a moment but what he's really getting at is
why this subject predicate understanding where
the subject is kind of uh just a hanger to
put predicates on why that can't capture what's
going on in in philosophy and in our relations
with the world our understanding of our self
are situating ourselves in history so that's
a lot of you know uh
backstory you might say or or revealing what's
going on but i think that's kind of helpful
here so he says formally what's been said
the general nature of the judgment or proposition
so when we engage in a judgment we are we
are affirming that something is the case or
we are deciding that something is a case we're
saying that it appears that way to us a proposition
is expressing that something is the case and
you might say what's the difference between
those one involves sort of an active stance
upon whatever it is that we're discussing
the other can be much more passive a proposition
can be just kind of floating out there and
you say well yeah i i think that's the way
it is when you say that you're making a judgment
about your relation to the proposition so
the the general form of the or the general
nature of the judgment or proposition involves
a distinction between subject and predicate
i am a college professor i am the subject
predicate is a college professor or just college
professor and we can say there's a copula
there the verb is depending on how we want
to parse this out now he says it's destroyed
by the speculative proposition so this seems
to imply that there is something out there
called the speculative proposition that you
know speculative zonza's is proposition or
sentence and that's not actually going to
be the case we might say better the speculative
handling of propositions because as we're
going to see a little bit later on we can't
completely get away from this we can't get
away from grammar we can't get away from using
words in ways that are familiar to us even
while we're doing speculative philosophy so
then he says it's destroyed by the speculative
proposition and the proposition of identity
or the identity proposition
is how the german runs which the former becomes
contains the counter thrust against that subject
predicate relationship so he's saying it it
doesn't completely destroy it it doesn't do
away with subject and predicate but what it
does is it gives us a richer relationship
between them that we can actually understand
we can wrap our heads around so we've seen
this quite often uh in in the previous proposition
or the previous sections right he'll say the
subject which we take to be sort of an inert
thing we take it as that which we know best
and we just sort of predicate other things
of it turns out that when we look at it closely
if the subject really is a subject it's got
agency it is not passive and the subject sort
of ebbs or you know bleeds itself into the
predicate and the predicate becomes the thing
that we actually know the subject through
later on he's going to talk and also in the
logic he's going to talk about essence and
appearance you know essence shows itself by
appearing by by having some sort of agency
by having some sort of activity and in this
he says there's a difference between the subject
and the predicate uh and we've seen this you
know played out in many passages so far you
know things self-other and if they're self-moving
objects or self-moving subjects what they
do is they become other to themselves and
then they reincorporate that otherness into
themselves that's this establishment of difference
and then there's i almost put unity at first
but it really is unification of the subject
and the predicate how do they become unified
by us knowing the subject through its predicate
by us realizing that the subject becomes other
to itself through having the predicate and
then it gets reappropriated into that so he
says how should we understand this and this
is where he's got a really interesting metaphor
a musical metaphor now you have to understand
a little bit about uh ancient um use of of
rhythm meter and stress in poetry for this
to make sense to you so i'm gonna give you
a little bit of a background on that ancient
greek and latin poetry does not concentrate
on end rhyme like our poetry does in english
i mean and so what what they focus on is meter
so you know you could have a foot as they
call it um where it's long short short or
you could have you know short short long these
are different kinds of feet short short long
long that's what we call a meter and what
do they mean by long there well the the word
would be stretched out and that would be done
because certain vowels had you know long quantity
and other vowels would be short so you know
here's just a a line from i forget exactly
who this is from it might be an acronym
so that's that's a very short poetic piece
and you notice that it has a rhythm to it
so it's got a meter to it and if we wanted
to express that meter it'd be
almost like morse code right short long morse
code is kind of like that now we add to it
the accent accent means stress
we put that in there and we can do this with
with this you know
if we're doing it like that
we might change the accent up
da
you know and that changes the way that it
comes across that's changing the rhythm now
we don't have this like i said very much in
our current poetry when it's done with some
sort of verse we tend to have fairly simple
constructions iambic pentameter is a good
example of that
is that the bright should be five feet pentameter
um and it's you know it's it's it's just going
like that you can you can monkey around with
it a bit when you actually know how to do
it right but that's the basic idea greek and
latin poetry used that as its basis for for
rhythm german poetry and we're talking about
like you know really old german poetry things
like the naval logan lead didn't worry so
much about meter but they did worry about
accent and they use the thing called stab
run which means stress run now we have something
like this it's used in lyricism in in songs
and it's used particularly in spoken word
music like rapper hip-hop where the rhythm
really matters and the rhythm is consisting
of meter and accent so all of that that's
fine now we've got that down why why does
hegel bring that up and why why did i bother
to explain that notice that it doesn't have
this sort of connection it's not like there's
a subject and then we just predicate things
of it sort of like putting you know first
we have greg sadler the body and then we put
on a shirt and then we put out a tie and then
we put on a jacket covering it instead these
things interpenetrate each other that's the
really key thing here rhythm is a kind of
harmony a coming together harmoniously sympathetically
interpenetrating each other of meter and accent
similarly hegel is saying that conceptually
what's going on in the notion is the subject
and the predicate are interpenetrating each
other how are they doing that through us we're
able to to understand them like that so he
says the form of the proposition is the appearance
of the determinate sense or the accent that
distinguishes its fulfillment but that the
predicate expresses the substance and that
the subject itself falls into the universal
this is the unity in which the accent dies
away so what we're looking at here is really
the the death of the subject if we want to
be very dramatic about that and he's got much
more to say about that but we'll look at that
in in future uh sections
to illustrate what has been said in the proposition
god is being the predicate is being it has
the significance of something substantial
in which the subject is dissolved being is
here meant to be not a predicate but rather
the essence it seems consequently that god
ceases to be what he is from his position
in the proposition that is a fixed subject
here thinking instead of making progress in
the transition from subject to predicate in
reality feels itself checked by the loss of
the subject and missing it is thrown back
on the thought of the subject or since the
predicate itself has been expressed as a subject
as the being or essence which exhausts the
nature of the subject thinking finds the subject
immediately in the predicate and now having
returned into itself in the predicate instead
of being in a position where it has freedom
for argument it is still absorbed in the content
or at least is faced with the demand that
it should be similarly to when one says the
actual is the universal the actual as subject
disappears in its predicate the universal
is not meant to even have entirely the significance
of a predicate as if the proposition asserted
only that the actual is universal on the contrary
the universal is meant to express the essence
of the actual thinking therefore loses the
firm objective basis it had in the subject
when in the predicate it is thrown back onto
the subject and when in the predicate it does
not return into itself but into the subject
of the content
in section 62 hegel is giving us a very helpful
illustration actually two illustrations of
what he's just been trying to get across to
us in the last several paragraphs and again
we're dealing with subject and predicate relations
and so he wants to say consider this this
example god is being so you know why would
somebody say that well it's really a commonplace
if you are a traditional theist of a certain
sort um this is actually where a lot of people
who are not theists or who are not traditional
theists actually misunderstand some of the
ontological claims lying behind traditional
theism you know traditional christian traditional
jewish traditional muslim ideas of things
you know god doesn't have being for somebody
like saint anselm god is being being in a
certain sense is not exactly what it is for
things like me or or the chalk only the absolute
being truly is being as as such so if we want
to know the nature of being then we have to
somehow penetrate into the mystery of knowing
what what god is right now you don't have
to necessarily accept that in order to understand
what we're saying here and what we're getting
at so hegel is picking up on something that
you know say thomas aquinas could have could
have put forward or rene descartes could have
put forward um and he's saying let's consider
this now in this proposition god is being
what is going on we have god as the subject
grammatically god is we're saying something
about god we're predicating something about
god and what are we doing we're saying god
is being we could also say god is merciful
or god is loving or god is angry today or
god is you know 23 and a half centimeters
tall you know we could come up with all sorts
of predicates but we're picking is being at
this time so he says
being as the predicate has the significance
of something substantial in which the subject
is dissolved so i'm going to put a number
of things up here just you know adding to
our understanding what would have said so
being here is something that is substantial
it's saying god is a kind of thing god is
a kind of substance whatever being happens
to be in the fullest sense and from the vantage
point of the thinking subject now we've seen
this before the subject is passing over into
its predicate if we want to know what the
subject is we can't just assume it as a fixed
starting point um you know there's ways of
doing philosophy where that's precisely what
you do you begin with these fixed axioms and
then you know move out from there hegel is
saying no if we actually want to learn anything
about anything that's not the way we actually
do it we begin with something that we think
that we know then we predicate something and
it turns out that the predicate is a hell
of a lot more intelligible than what we began
with and now we say ah now i get it what this
is is this actually thing this over here now
i'm starting to understand
so being is something substantial in that
case and the subject is being dissolved he
says being is here not meant to be a predicate
that's why i have this predicate or but rather
the
essence the vase in in german the very being
of the being in a certain sense and what's
the significance of this to say that it's
it's not just a predicate but the essence
it's saying that we're getting at the heart
of the thing if we want to say something like
imagine we're trying to talk about a person
and you say i want to hire this guy um what
can you tell me about him you know he starts
out with sort of an x and maybe he's got you
know certain attributes he walks into the
office he's dressed in a coat and tie and
you say is this guy a schmuck is he you know
somebody who's high caliber is he a thief
is he a stand-up guy now you're asking me
for predicates and if you're if you want to
get to the very heart of the matter you're
actually looking for something like an essence
you're actually looking for me to tell you
who is this person at heart who is this person
at his core and so let's say that i actually
have known this person my entire life and
i say this is somebody who you don't want
to trust i could tell you all sorts of stories
about him but i'm going to crystallize those
in one thing that i'm going to say he is totally
disreputable now i'm saying something about
that person's essence could be false could
be true don't worry about that at this point
the main thing is to see what hegel is actually
talking about here when he's talking about
essence talking about something that's part
of the matter and now all the other stuff
about that guy just kind of dissolves into
this this thing that i've predicated of him
or the essence which i've revealed that becomes
his his substantiality and another way of
thinking about this is the subject has been
lost the thinking subject which is us we're
watching the subject being lost why well because
what's happened over here is we actually have
the predicate as a new kind of subject something
else that we can say something more about
right so he says the thinking instead of making
progress in the transition from subject to
predicate in reality feels itself checked
by the loss of the subject missing it is thrown
back onto the thought of the subject or since
the predicate itself has been expressed as
subject as the being the essence which exhausts
the nature of the subject thinking finds the
subject immediately in the predicate so what
is the subject here it's really this here
and now we've found it within the predicate
who was this guy that you were thinking of
interviewing that you have sitting in your
office biding his time while you you know
come out and talk with me turns out that it's
this over here that's the same thing and it's
caught up within the the side of the predicament
so he says um now having returned to itself
in the predicate instead of being in a position
where it has freedom for argument it's still
absorbed in the content it becomes absorbed
in in this side or at least it's faced with
the demand that it should be now hegel is
going to give us another example so instead
of god as being and you know we start to look
at what is being and then you know once we
start to explore it a bit we find out that
god is there inside of being and it gets very
complicated let's look instead at some other
possibility the actual there's our subject
is the universal what the hell does that mean
well in this case he says the universal is
not meant to have merely the significance
of a predicate as if the proposition asserted
only that the actual is universal on the contrary
the universal is meant to express the once
again essence of the subject what it is to
be actual is to be universal now we could
tell a story he's going to tell all sorts
of stories about how this works let me just
give you the thumb the quickest of thumbnail
sketches about that part of what's going on
with hegel when he says that the actual is
universal means that when something actually
exists and has agency when it matters it assumes
a kind of universalizing status you might
think of it as able to spread itself out into
multiple contexts we use this word transfer
in education to talk from going from area
to area to area and we can think about that
as also applying to to human beings so if
it works for me then if it's actual for me
then it's potentially actual for you you can
relate to it it's attaining a kind of universality
if you become attracted into that i might
be the trendsetter who who starts something
actual and now you're doing it i mean think
about for example this this as i forget which
cultural critic called it but part of the
costume of the bourgeois man the tie right
at one point this was you know an innovation
somebody started out with this and eventually
caught on and it attained a kind of universality
do you have to wear a tie in a business setting
or a professorial academic setting no as a
matter of fact you might actually by you using
the tie uh negatively produce the absence
of the tie you show a kind of informality
or transcending the tie but you're still using
it as a universal in that case do you see
how that that works um so anyway back to this
same sort of dynamic is going on the subject
gets lost within the predicate and then gets
found within the predicate again we conceptualize
we come to understand we attain the intelligibility
of what it is to be actual by looking at this
process of becoming universal so he says thinking
therefore loses the firm objective basis it
had in the subject that it began with when
in the predicate it's thrown back onto the
subject and when in the predicate it does
not return to itself but into the subject
of the content so we've got this back and
forth dialectic going on and this is not something
that attains a completely fixed um satisfying
position at this point we're gonna have to
go on further uh with respect to that this
is part of why the dialectic is dynamic negativity
is pulling it through you can say and the
negativity is partly on the part of the thinking
subject
this abnormal inhibition of thought is in
large measure the source of the complaints
regarding the unintelligibility of philosophical
writings from individuals who otherwise possess
the educational requirements for understanding
them here we see the reason behind one particular
complaint so often made against them that
so much has to be read over and over before
it can be understood a complaint whose burden
is presumed to be quite outrageous and if
justified to admit of no defense it is clear
from the above what this amounts to the philosophical
proposition since it is a proposition leads
one to believe that the usual subject predicate
relation obtains as well as the usual attitude
towards knowing but the philosophical content
destroys this attitude in this opinion we
learn by experience that we meant something
other than we meant to mean and this correction
of our meaning compels our knowing to go back
to the proposition and understand it in some
other way
so section 63 is dealing with something that
is really close to my own experience and and
my heart and it's actually kind of funny to
think about and probably something that a
lot of people out there can can relate to
as well on both both sides the um claiming
things are unintelligible side and the being
surprised by the fact that other people find
it unintelligible and dismiss it for that
reason so hegel's looking at this common complaint
about philosophical writings philosophical
works and i think this is just as true today
as it it was back in his time it's probably
always going to be true he's probably got
his finger on on something very important
there as a matter of fact as a corollary if
he's actually right about this then it's probably
the case that anything that is easily grasped
and understood as such is probably if not
already at least on the verge of becoming
crap philosophy which is to say not philosophy
at all but just sort of mumbling along using
some words doing group thing you know we could
come up with all sorts of uh other ways of
expressing this so he says the this abnormal
inhibition of thought what does he mean there
going back to um previous two sections the
the thinking subject trying to make sense
out of philosophical propositions which which
do have this subject predicate form and going
back and forth finding that the subject loses
itself in the predicate but the predicate
doesn't seem to get reabsorbed back into the
subject but we find the subject within it
and so there's a kind of circularity there
that that tends to discomfort people tends
to produce cognitive dissonance particularly
since we always tend to think that if there's
some circularity there that it's vicious circularity
hagel's saying that it's not so he says it's
the source of the complaints regarding the
unintelligibility of philosophical writings
and here's where he says something really
interesting from individuals who otherwise
possess the educational requirements for understanding
them so he's not worried about people who
you know because either they they rejected
the opportunities given them or they were
never given the opportunities or they simply
aren't up to it with their mental capacities
the people who haven't had a good education
he's saying that even among the people who've
had a good education quite a few of them can't
understand philosophy this is true today
why is it true well because when you're really
doing philosophy you're engaging in a highly
abstract reflexive thinking process that there
aren't hard and fast rules for and requires
you to do quite a bit of personal development
in order to be able to to make it work like
i say to my students quite often if you're
reading the text and it's a classic text and
you're not getting anything out of it there's
no problem with the text there's a problem
with you and what you need to do is figure
out how not to adapt the text to you via spark
notes or you know wikipedia articles or things
like that you need to figure out how to adapt
your brain your mind your intellect to that
text because there's something out there that
provides the standard for you and usually
what i'll do is i'll say look at these other
students they're not any you know smarter
or dumber than you and yet they're able to
understand what plato's talking about because
here here's their paper so when you say i
just don't get it or it's unintelligible that's
actually a mark against you not a mark against
the material so he says here we see the one
of the reasons so much has to be read over
and over before it can be understood the complaint
whose burden is presumed to be quite outrageous
if it's not clear the first time around then
you know there's something wrong with it i
see this in comments on my videos quite frequently
um you know there's there's two ways in which
people frequently go wrong that i think hegel
could relate to one is that you know i'll
say in the description to the video we're
covering this idea or this section and they'll
they'll ask me about all sorts of stuff way
over here you know we're talking about something
in plato and we're not talking about the theory
of the forms and then they want to ask me
about the theory of the forms or or suggest
that that's important here or you know they
don't want to actually hunker down and just
fix their attention on this and see where
this actually goes that's that's one problem
same thing comes up sometimes in these these
half hour hegel videos and some of the comments
on them um the other thing is it does take
you know going over this material several
times in many cases and actually going to
the text to make sense of it so you know another
kind of comment that i get is people will
um ask me questions or raise objections or
get into arguments based on what i'm saying
in the video and they're not reading the actual
text that the video is just merely at best
a reflection of same thing with this you know
if you're watching this and you're hoping
that i'm going to communicate hegel to you
and you're not going to have to read it there's
something wrong here you actually do have
to do the work the intellectual labor like
hegel said the patience the labor uh of the
negative you have to put that that work in
in order to reap the benefits and sometimes
sometimes benefits are intellectual so he's
saying there's a lot of people in my day who
you know they didn't have spark notes what
they would do is read book reviews what did
kant to say about this i'm not going to read
the con i'll just read you know so-and-so's
book review of it that'll be good enough for
me how do you know it's sort of like the same
problem with knowing what's a good translation
or a bad translation if you don't read the
original how do you know if the translation
of hegel is good how do you know if the translation
of plato is good if you don't read greek or
you don't read german and you don't actually
i mean it's one thing to be able to read greek
or german it's another actually go to the
text and say i don't understand why he translated
it this way so these are all sort of good
considerations to to bring to the table this
common complaint philosophical writings are
unintelligible here's a bunch of questions
that we ought to be asking that person when
somebody says that they're unintelligible
do they just mean they're unintelligible to
me and that's a mark against me because maybe
they are intelligible a lot of other people
say that they are i just can't seem to get
it that's not usually what the person is saying
though is it usually they're saying well because
it's unintelligible to me it's unintelligible
to everyone or it's unintelligible in itself
because i can't understand kant's kant doesn't
make any sense to anybody he can't possibly
be right that's the sign of somebody who is
in a certain respect well educated but in
a certain respect an ignoramus to assume that
simply because oneself one is not in a you
know a position to understand something that
it is therefore completely unintelligible
to everybody when the evidence is other people
saying no this actually can be understood
it's really a kind of uh strange defense mechanism
or narcissism that people do but hegel's saying
look people do this quite often so he says
it's clear from the above what this amounts
to why does this happen well there's a reason
for this the philosophical proposition is
in fact a proposition it does in fact have
this subject predicate form so that seduces
us into thinking when we say something like
god is being let's say we take anselm's prosologia
right um god is not only being god cannot
you know by the time we get to chapter four
god cannot even be coherently thought not
to exist he must of necessity exist and yet
god is if you read further in besides the
so-called ontological proof god is greater
than what we understand is as necessity well
that's kind of mind-blowing stuff and if you
think that the first time you read through
it you're going to get it just like that you
you really have another thing coming concepts
if they're important concepts that they're
actual you know robust concepts they take
us a while to come to terms with i've been
reading anselm's prosthologion for close to
20 years now and i still go back and forth
as i read about is does this make sense or
doesn't this make sense and i've had you know
a few experiences where you sort of break
through to the other side and now you see
things in very different ways as a result
but that's because you know he's working with
philosophical propositions hegel is too hegel
is going to actually consider anselm not in
this but in his um uh lectures on the philosophy
of religion and the so-called ontological
proof um so he's saying the philosophical
content destroys the attitude and opinion
of the normal way of dealing with subject
predicate this is something that we've seen
so far we learned by experience that we meant
something other than we meant to mean this
is kind of a funny thing we learn from experience
what experience the experience of thinking
also the experience of reading somebody else
also the experience of trying to communicate
those insights with other people also the
experience of trying to take this you know
batch of ideas and apply them to the world
into our own experience we have experience
about experience we have experience about
trying to conceptualize trying to make sense
out of in a dynamic adequate way our experience
so we have an experience he says of that we
meant something other than what we mean we
meant to mean you know might you might say
this is totally incoherent no we we have this
sort of experience all the time we are fallible
creatures we start out thinking one thing
and we come out the other end of the tunnel
thinking something different and what took
place in the middle we thought more about
it we realized that we were actually wrong
about things when we i got the subject predicate
over here we think that we know what a subject
is we predicate some things a bit we think
about what that predicate means the predicate
reveals the essence and now we see the subject
in a whole different way there's nothing mysterious
about this there is something laborious about
this and because it's laborious a lot of people
are unwilling to put in the time but if you
don't put in the time you won't receive the
benefit which is making sense out of what
it is not just that hegel has here in this
book but the vistas that hegel is opening
up to us